well more drama is expected in the
British Parliament today after lawmakers
rejected a no deal withdrawal from the
EU voting last night paves the way for
another vote today to delay Britain's
exit date beyond March the 29th but
British prime minister Theresa May has
also set out plans for a third
parliamentary vote on her overall breaks
a deal with Europe that vote is supposed
to be held by March the 20th responding
to her latest defeat a very hoarse Prime
Minister had this to say
UK and EU local remains that the UK will
leave the EU without a deal something
else is agreed the onus is now on every
one of us in this house to find out what
that is the options before us are the
same as they always have been we could
leave we could leave with the deal which
this government is negotiations in the
past two years we could leave with the
deal we happen to go see 80 but subject
to a second referendum but that would
risk no brexit at a number of options
out there so what happens next joining
us now for the latest is DW spagett mass
in London and max Hoffman our Brussels
bureau chief a good morning to both of
you a baguette if we could start with
you this morning Theresa May has said
that the situation right now
is that in spite of last night's vote
the brexit options remain the same is
that where we are right now no something
has changed what she's talking about is
her deal is the only deal basically
that's still on the table and she's
still hoping also to get it through
because now she really can exert more
pressure on parliamentarians because the
choice is this as she puts it it's my
deal to his amazed eel that she's
hammered out with the European Union or
either no brexit at all or a really long
lengthy brexit process in which
everything can happen a second
referendum could happen so Theresa may
will once again try and put Hardy
on the table because she knows that for
those people who want out in her own
party there are many of them they will
now think long and hard that might be
their last chance that they get to exit
the European Union so maybe if there is
yet one mother she might just get her
well she might get her deal true okay
we might also see an extension voted on
today and in a possible extension max
how would the EU respond to that
scenario had you asked me that question
a couple of weeks ago Brian I would have
said definitely they'll say okay but
their stance has toughened a little bit
in the last days they've made it clear
that they need a reason to extend
whether this be a short extension a
technical extension that's what it could
be would be called for two or three
months or a longer extension beyond the
European elections in May and the
possible reason for example is a second
referendum or maybe even snap elections
or as Teresa may put it if she puts that
deal up for another vote and it gets
passed that would also be neat for a
technical extension because now the time
has run out to really implement any kind
of deal and until the 29th of March so
you would need a couple of extra weeks
or even extra months to be able to
implement that the EU wouldn't have any
problem in granting that technical
extension if the parliaments or the
House of Commons said okay to their deal
everything else seems up in the air
because it doesn't look like the House
of Commons beyond maybe approving that
deal seems able to clarify what this
extension should really be for okay
max just mentioned the technical
extension turned they're looking at a
possible date of May or or June can the
British government work in Parliament
guarantee that at the end of that
process at the end of that date we're
not going to repeat everything we've
been over this week all again in May or
June thinking here in London is like max
has said two possibilities and MPs will
get a vote
later today what sort of extension the
Prime Minister is looking for from the
EU
either a short one at which the deal to
resume still will most likely be
implemented or a long one which would
give just more leverage to those who are
fighting for a second referendum
so-called people's fate and that is a
longer period that might be a few years
and in this few years we have another
long period of uncertainty uncertainty
so these two options are really on the
table at the moment but like Mark said
the EQ has to agree for so one thing
what parliamentarians he and London want
and the other thing what can actually be
agreed with the European Union
okay max what does it look like in
Brussels you know we're talking about
the technical extension there's also the
longer extension I could be up for up to
two years that's a speculation right now
what would Brussels do in that case yeah
I mean just to be clear here and then
bergens absolutely right in mentioning
that the reaction Wednesday night from
the EU Commission was it's all good and
well that the House of Commons decides
that there won't be a No Deal brexit but
really that's still the default option
and in order to really avoid a No Deal
brexit you need a deal so that's still
where we are we call it the brexit
conundrum right here and because of this
situation you have more and more EU
lawmakers and we talked to many of them
over the course of this week who are
pushing for a second referendum
especially of course the Social
Democrats because that's the same line
that labor has though the Social
Democratic party back in the UK but that
would only be possible with the longer
extension if we are talking one or two
years but that of course has different
problems for example the European
elections in May if we go beyond that
date significantly go beyond that day
then the UK would have to participate in
those elections if that would be awkward
wouldn't it you have a country that
actually wanted to leave but still has
to participate in the EU elections
something that many lawmakers want to
avoid because it might hijack the the
actual topics you know the actual things
they want to talk about and there are
many of them
migration climate change just to mention
two of them okay max Hoffman forests in
Brussels big at Moss in London thanks so
much for bringing us up-to-date as
another vote looms too
in the British Parliament